THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP CLAIMING VICTORY
AFTER THE RELEASE OF THE MUELLER
REPORT.
>> I'M HAVING A GOOD DAY TOO.
IT'S CALLED NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
THERE NEVER WAS, BY THE WAY, AND
THERE NEVER WILL BE.
AND WE DO HAVE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THESE THINGS.
I SAY IT IN FRONT OF MY FRIENDS.
THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
ANOTHER PRESIDENT AGAIN.
THIS HOAX SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
>> Jesse: TRUMP'S REACTION
COMING AFTER AG WILLIAM BARR'S
NEWS CONFERENCE WHERE HE ONCE
AGAIN CLEARED THE PRESIDENT AND
CONFIRMED THERE WAS NO COLLUSION
AND NO OBSTRUCTION.
>> THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL CONFIRMED
THAT THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED EFFORTS TO ILLEGALLY
INTERFERE WITH THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
BUT DID NOT FIND THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OR OTHER AMERICANS
COLLUDED IN THOSE EFFORTS.
>> Jesse: NOW THE FOCUS HAS
TURNED TO OBSTRUCTION.
SOME DEMOCRATS INSISTING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP BROKE THE LAW,
BUT AG BARR SAYS THAT'S NOT
CREDIBLE.
>> THE REPORT RECOUNTS EPISODES
INVOLVING THE PRESIDENT AND
DISCUSSES POTENTIAL LEGAL
THEORIES FOR CONNECTING THOSE
ACTIVITIES TO THE ELEMENTS OF AN
OBSTRUCTION OFFENSE.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
I CONCLUDED THAT THE EVIDENCE
DEVELOPED BY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO ESTABLISH
THE PRESIDENT COMMITTED AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE OFFENSE.
ALTHOUGH THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND I DISAGREED WITH
SOME OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
LEGAL THEORIES AND FELT THAT
SOME OF THE EPISODES EXAMINED
DID NOT AMOUNT TO OBSTRUCTION AS
A MATTER OF LAW.
>> Jesse: FOR MORE ON WHAT'S
MUELLER REPORT, LET'S GO TO
ED HENRY.
>> RUDY GIULIANI TEXTED ME THIS
WAS "A KNOCKOUT BLOW" FOR THE
PRESIDENT WHEN IT COMES TO HIS
CRITICS.
AFTER 22 MONTHS AND $25 MILLION,
THE STORY DID NOT REALLY CHANGE
MUCH TODAY.
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
MADE IT CLEAR YET AGAIN, JUST AS
HE DID IN HIS LETTER TO CONGRESS
LAST MONTH, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
FOUND NO COLLUSION BY ANY
AMERICANS WITH RUSSIA, INCLUDING
TRUMP AIDS.
BARR DECLARING WHILE YES, RUSSIA
TRIED TO INTERFERE IN THE LAST
ELECTION, THEY DID NOT GET HELP
FROM KENDRA TRUMP OR HIS AIDES.
DEMOCRATS CLAIMING THEY HAD
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, ROBERT
MUELLER NEVER FOUND IT.
DESPITE DEMOCRATS AND PUNDITS
REPEATEDLY HINTING THAT
DONALD TRUMP JR. WAS GOING TO BE
INDICTED OVER THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETING, THE BOTTOM LINE IS IT
WAS NOT CRIMINAL.
THAT'S PART OF VOLUME TWO OF THE
MUELLER REPORT WHICH IS MORE
DAMAGING TO THE PRESIDENT.
SPECIAL COUNSEL DETAIL TEN
INSTANCES WHERE THE PRESIDENT
ACTED IN A WAY THAT RAISED
QUESTIONS AT LEAST ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
MUELLER DECLARING IN HIS REPORT
"WHILE THIS REPORT IS NOT
CONCLUDED THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED A CRIME, IT ALSO DOES
NOT EXONERATE HIM."
THIS HAS SHIFTED FROM A LEGAL
FIGHT TO A POLITICAL FIGHT.
TO BE 24 DECLARING TO REPORTERS
IT'S NOT GAME OR FOR HIS
INVESTIGATING OF THE PRESIDENT,
WHILE GIULIANI SEEMS DELIGHTED
ABOUT MORE INVESTIGATIONS WHICH
HE SEES AS PARTISAN.
GIULIANI JUST TEXTED ME AGAIN A
FEW MINUTES AGO SAYING "THE
COMMENTARIAT IS REELING."
>> Jesse: THANK YOU, ED HENRY.
GOING THROUGH THE REPORT BIG
TIME.
THAT'S HOW BIG IT IS.
I HAVE IT COLOR-CODED AND WE ARE
GOING TO REFER TO THOSE COLOR
CODES LATER.
DAN, I WANTED TO GET TO YOU
FIRST.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THE
STORY CLOSELY.
THE WAY I SEE IT, THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN FALSELY ACCUSED OF
BEING A TRAITOR.
MILLER HAS CONCLUDED THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT A TRADER AND
THE DEMOCRATS, INSTEAD OF BEING
HAPPY, THEY ARE ANGRY ABOUT THE
WAY THE PRESIDENT FOUGHT BACK
AGAINST THE FALSE ALLEGATIONS
THAT HE WAS A TRAITOR.
>> Dan: THEY ARE ANGRY THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS ANGRY THAT HE
WAS FALSELY ACCUSED.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
THERE WAS NEVER EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION, EVER.
THIS REPORT IS A DISGRACE.
WHOEVER WROTE THIS REPORT,
MUELLER, WEISSMANN AND HIS TEAM
OF DEMOCRATS FRAMED IT IN SUCH A
WAY TO LEAVE OUT SIGNIFICANT
FACTS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION IN THERE BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T FABRICATE IT.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE PAPADOPOULOS
SECTION, I'M TALKING ABOUT THIS
ALONE, ON THE PAPADOPOULOS
SECTION, THEY LEAVE OUT THE FACT
THAT JOSEPH MIFSUD HAD DEEP
CONNECTIONS TO WESTERN
INTELLIGENCE TOO.
LOOK IT UP ON GOOGLE.
THERE'S PICTURES WITH U.K.
INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE.
ON THE TRUMP TOWER MEETING, THEY
LEAVE OUT THAT THE RUSSIAN
LAWYER WHO SHOWS UP WAS WORKING
FOR THE SAME COMPANY WORKING FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
THIS OBSTRUCTION THING IS A
JOKE.
THE PRESIDENT IS FULLY
VINDICATED.
ANY RATIONAL PERSON READING THAT
KNOWS IT.
>> Jesse: RUDY GIULIANI SAID
EARLIER THAT THE RUSSIAN LAWYER
MET WITH FUSION GPS, THE DOSSIER
AUTHORS, THE DAY BEFORE THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING, THE DAY OF
IN THE DAY AFTER.
MUST HAVE BEEN A COINCIDENCE.
GREG, YOU'VE BEEN GOING TO
REPORT ALL DAY I KNOW.
>> Greg: NO.
I HAVEN'T READ IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M NEVER GOING
TO READ IT.
I SWEAR I'M NEVER GOING TO READ
IT.
THIS IS NOT NEWS TO ME.
IF YOU WERE CONSCIOUS ON
MARCH 24, YOU ALREADY KNEW, THAT
WAS CALLED A SPOILER ALERT WHEN
YOU WERE TOLD THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION AND NO OBSTRUCTION.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME AROUND
FOR ME AND IT FEELS PRETTY GOOD.
IT'S LIKE AROUND CHRISTMAS TIME,
THEY PLAY "DIE HARD."
YOU LOVE "DIE HARD."
THE ENDING IS GREAT FOR THE
ENDING IS ALWAYS THE SAME.
JOHN McLEAN WINS.
HANS GRUBER DIES.
THIS IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AMERICA AND THE REST OF THE
MEDIA.
AMERICA WATCHES "DIE HARD" AND
KNOWS THE ENDING AND ENJOYS IT.
THE MEDIA WATCHES DIE-HARD AND
THINGS THE ENDING IS GOING TO
CHANGE, THAT SOMEHOW HANS GRUBER
IS NOT GOING TO DIE AND JOHN
McLEAN IS GOING TO BE
ARRESTED.
SO IN THREE WEEKS NOW, THEY HAVE
WATCHED "DIE HARD" TWICE AND
THEY'VE HAD THEIR HEARTS BROKEN.
I LOVE THIS.
CNN'S RATINGS ARE VERY LOW RIGHT
NOW BUT THE RATINGS THEY HAVE I
BELIEVE ARE BASED ON COMIC
RELIEF.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING THERE
AND WATCHING YOU JUST FOR THE
HILARITY.
I WANT TO ADDRESS THE ONE THING
IS TRUE -- WHAT'S HIS NAME,
ED HENRY?
WHERE DOES HE WORK?
>> Marie: HE'S ONE OF OURS.
>> Greg: NICE GUY.
HE RAN THROUGH THE LAUNDRY LIST
FALLACY, TEN INSTANCES THAT
RAISE QUESTIONS.
TAKE EACH INSTANCE ON ITS OWN,
DOESN'T RAISE ANYTHING.
IT SAYS THERE'S NOTHING THERE.
SO INSTEAD USE STEP BACK AND YOU
SAY THERE ARE TEN.
IF THERE TEN ZEROS, TEN TIMES
ZERO IS STILL ZERO.
IT'S CALLED A LAUNDRY LIST
FALLACY THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
STRONG ARGUMENT, YOU HAVE TEN
SMALL ARGUMENTS THAT YOU ADD UP
AND YOU END UP WITH THIS
OBSESSIVE, OBSESSIVE FASCINATIO
FASCINATION.
GOING THROUGH THE REPORT AND
LOOKING FOR A LITTLE ZEROS.
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN ENTIRE
INDUSTRY DEVOTED TO SOLVING BIG
FOOT AND THE LOCH NESS MONSTER.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS ALSO YOUR
POINT DURING THE KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS, THAT YOU JUST KEEP
THROWING MORE AND MORE
ALLEGATIONS, IT BUILDS UP INTO
SOMETHING MORE DIFFERENT.
THE HANS GRUBER OF THE TABLE.
>> Greg: OH!
ALAN RICKMAN WAS A GREAT ACTOR.
>> Jesse: HE WAS A GREAT
ACTOR.
>> Marie: ON OBSTRUCTION,
MUELLER MAKES CLEAR THEY ARE NOT
SAY NO OBSTRUCTION.
HE SAYS IT IN PLAIN LANGUAGE.
WE ARE UNABLE TO REACH THE
JUDGMENT OF THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT COMMIT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> Jesse: HE JUST DIDN'T
CHARGE HIM.
>> Marie: THOSE ARE TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
HE OUTLINES LEGALLY WHAT HE
COULD NOT UNDER THE EXISTING
GUIDELINES CHARGE THE PRESIDENT.
HE OUTLINES A CASE FOR
OBSTRUCTION AND THEN IN PLAIN
TEXT AS IT'S UP TO THE CONGRESS
TO DECIDE IF THIS OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE WHICH BY THE WAY SPENT
PART OF TWO ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT FOR NIXON AND
CLINTON, OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
THAT THIS RISES TO THE LEVEL.
>> Jesse: HE SAID IF CONGRESS
WANTS TO DO HIS OWN
INVESTIGATION, THEY ARE ABLE
TO --
>> Marie: HE SET UP CONGRESS
MAY APPLY THE OBSTRUCTION LOSS.
HE SAYS THAT CLEARLY.
>> Jesse: HE DOESN'T SAY THIS
WAS THE PRODUCT OF HERE YOU GO,
CONGRESS, TAKE IT WHERE I LEFT
IT.
HE SAID IF THEY WANT TO DO THEIR
OWN INVESTIGATION, THEY CAN.
>> Marie: THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY
WHAT HE SAID BUT --
>> Jesse: IF YOU READ IT
CLOSELY, THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> Marie: HE SENT CLEARLY I'M
NOT SAYING THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
COMMIT OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HE ALSO DOES NOT SAY THERE'S NO
COLLUSION.
HE SAYS THERE IS NO CONSPIRACY
OR COORDINATION THAT ROSE TO THE
LEVEL OF CRIMINAL STANDARDS.
HE -- AND THEN HE OUTLINES VERY
CLEARLY MULTIPLE CONTACTS
BETWEEN TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
RUSSIANS.
>> Dan: IS THAT ILLEGAL?
>> Marie: MY FINAL POINT,
WHICH HAVE HIGHER STANDARDS FOR
OUR PRESIDENT THAN WHETHER
THINGS ARE ILLEGAL.
I READ THIS AND SAW IT MAY NOT
BE ILLEGAL.
I FIND IT ABHORRENT, UNETHICAL,
NOTHING AND THE OTHER DEMOCRAT
OR REPUBLICAN --
>> Greg: SHOULD HAVE FEWER
RIGHTS THAN YOU?
>> Marie: I DON'T THINK ANY
OTHER PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
WOULD EVER ENGAGE IN THIS KIND
OF BEHAVIOR AND I DON'T WANT MY
PRESIDENT DOING IT.
>> Greg: DOES HE HAVE LESS
RIGHTS?
HE RELEASED IT.
I WOULDN'T HAVE RELEASED IT.
>> Dan: MEETING WITH RUSSIANS
IS ILLEGAL OR UNETHICAL?
>> Marie: TRYING TO ACCEPT
HELP TO INFLUENCE AN ELECTION.
>> Jesse: HILLARY CLINTON --
LET'S GO, DANA.
>> Marie: I THINK WE NEED TO
READ THE ACTUAL REPORTS.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
THIS IS?
IT'S ALL BEEN READ.
BE 45 MINUTES.
>> Greg: AMAZING.
SPEED READER.
>> Jesse: REDACTED INFORMATION
FROM GRAND JURY TESTIMONY.
>> Dana: THERE WAS ONE NUGGET
THAT I'VE BEEN CURIOUS ABOUT AND
YOU FIND OUT ESSENTIALLY NOTHING
THERE.
GO BACK WITH ME BACK IN TIME TO
THE 2016 RNC CONVENTION AND THE
LANGUAGE OF THE PLATFORM GETS
CHANGED ON UKRAINE, THAT WE WERE
GOING TO SUPPORT WITH ARMS AND
THEN IT GETS WATERED DOWN.
EVELYN WAS LIKE, HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN?
I WANT TO KNOW, HOW DID THAT
MAYBE MANAFORT HAS A SIDE DEAL
GOING ON BUT IT TURNS OUT NO, A
STAFFER, NOT IMPORTANT LEVEL
STAFFER THAT THOUGHT THEY HEARD
THE PRESIDENT AT SOME POINT
THINK THAT MAYBE HE WOULD RATHER
DO IT THIS WAY AND SO HE GETS
CHANGED.
FOR ALMOST THREE YEARS, THERE
HAS BEEN THE SUSPICION OUT THERE
THAT THERE WAS A CHANGE IN THE
RNC PLATFORM BASED ON SOME SORT